While some moviegoers might argue that the
perfect scene doesn't exist, quite a few Marvel
movies come darn close to proving that argument
wrong.
Buckle up, because we're diving headfirst
into the most memorable, iconic, and practically
flawless scenes in the MCU.
Iron Man is a masterpiece of a movie.
Robert Downey Jr.'s performance as Tony Stark
is exactly what the MCU needed to gain some
momentum right out of the gate.
"Yeah, peace.
I love peace.
I'd be out of a job with peace."
While it's a great experience from one end
to the other, though, there's one scene that
stands out above the rest.
We're talking about Stark's emergence from
captivity, decked out in the towering first
version of his Iron Man suit, the Mark I.
The clunky armor is a rough start compared
to the nanotech that Stark eventually creates.
It gets stuck in the wall and requires a handmade
spark to launch its missiles.
And it's not exactly durable.
But it's all he needs to blow that popsicle
stand and then hightail it out of there, leaving
the astonished survivors of the Ten Rings
in the rearview mirror.
The death of Yinsen adds some emotional fuel
to the fire, too, as he implores Stark not
to waste his life.
"Thank you for saving me."
"Don't waste it — don't waste your life."
The emergence of the MCU's first bona fide
superhero was pulled off with a precision
that simultaneously cut to the quick and had
us on our feet cheering.
Sometimes it's an unspoken understanding between
characters that makes a scene truly flawless.
Few action movie moments have done this as
well as Steve Rogers' reckless sacrifice at
training camp, when he throws himself on a
grenade that he doesn't know is a dummy.
This moment in Captain America: The First
Avenger punctuates a debate between Colonel
Chester Phillips and Dr. Abraham Erskine about
who should be recruited as the first "super
soldier" in their program.
Phillips casually tosses the grenade into
the midst of the new recruits, at which point
everyone scrambles.
The one exception?
Rogers.
"Get away!
The scene is a splendid illustration of Rogers'
ideals, all wrapped up into a single action.
Compare that to the moment in Endgame when
he faces down Thanos' entire army or the numerous
occasions in which he professed that he could,
quote, "do this all day."
That guy started as a skinny fella with a
heart of gold, ready to jump on a grenade
if that's what was required.
Even a superheroic transformation, decades
spent frozen in ice, and cosmic confrontations
with unimaginable evil couldn't take that
away from him.
Everything hits the fan when Thanos arrives
on the scene in Avengers: Infinity War.
While Endgame would eventually even the score
by dusting the Mad Titan and seeing the good
guys back on top, its predecessor marks one
of the first times Marvel actually ended things
on a sour note — and we mean a really sour
note.
The story comes to a fever pitch as Thanos
plucks the Mind Stone out of Vision's forehead,
completing his gauntlet, and then snaps his
fingers after Thor fails to finish him off.
The sequence that follows takes us across
the universe, showing the effects of the snap
as half of all life in existence crumbles
to ashes on the spot.
One moment on Titan is particularly emotional
as Spider-Man bids a desperate farewell to
his mentor, Tony Stark.
"I'm sorry."
Back on Earth, Steve Rogers' slow realization
that they have just lost is just as moving,
as he sits, slumped on the ground in defeat
with his friends turned to dust around him.
While it may not be fun, the Decimation is
one of the most flawlessly executed moments
in the entire MCU.
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo have brought
us many of the MCU's most compelling moments,
and their work makes it onto this list more
than once.
A particular highlight, though, is the Captain
America: Civil War's climactic confrontation.
The final moments of the film see Steve Rogers
and Bucky Barnes face off against a furious
Tony Stark, who has just discovered that it
was none other than a brainwashed Barnes himself
who killed his parents.
The scene is set against a cold, hard backdrop
of snow and stone as the heroes tangle through
an abandoned Cold War facility in Siberia.
Stark's superior armor seems to put him at
an advantage, but it's ultimately Rogers'
attitude that helps him defeat the Iron Avenger
by putting a shield through his arc reactor.
From stellar cinematography to the wrenching
emotional conflict to the choreography of
the fight itself, everything about this scene
is a home run.
Michael Rooker's Yondu Udonta steals the show
for a lot of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2.
However, the scene in which he stages a jailbreak
and then retakes his entire ship with the
help of Rocket and Baby Groot is particularly
priceless.
The scene, cheekily set to the needle drop
of Jay and the Americans' "Come a Little Bit
Closer," perfectly embodies the spirit of
the Guardians franchise.
Irreverent, careless, mindlessly violent,
unpredictable, self-destructive, and downright
hilarious, the sequence shows Yondu's Arrow
speed around the ship, hunting his mutinous
crew one by one until he finally takes out
Taserface… and the entire ship to boot.
The legendary feat firmly establishes Yondu
as a Mary Poppins-tier hero, y'all… and
just in time for him to make the sacrifice
play as the film wraps up.
The scene is deliciously tongue-in-cheek and
masterfully leaves the audience struggling
with a brand of morbid humor that only James
Gunn can so casually invoke.
"You maniac…"
The airport fight scene in Captain America:
Civil War is incredible on so many levels.
Though they've fought one-on-one plenty of
times, this is the one and only occasion that
the MCU's heroes have taken each other on
as teams.
And it's positively dripping with quality
action beats.
Naturally, the fighting is preceded by some
light banter, because even at their lowest
points, Marvel's heroes can't contain their
sarcasm.
Once the joking is finished, though, the divided
group gets down to business, and boy is it
fun to watch.
"Underoos!"
"Nice job, kid!"
"Thanks!"
The scene has Tom Holland's Spider-Man swinging
into action for the first time, even nabbing
Cap's shield while he's at it.
Scarlet Witch continues to showcase her impressive
powerset as well, and newcomer T'Challa cuts
a dashing figure in his vibranium Black Panther
suit.
Even Ant-Man makes a huge splash by transforming
into Giant-Man and wrecking everything in
his path.
The thrilling moments just keep on coming
with this one.
From start to finish, the airport fight is
one of the most exciting — and funniest
— action sequences that the MCU has ever
produced.
"I'm really sorry."
“You couldn't have done that earlier?"
"......I hate you."
Thor's character has come a long way since
those early Phase 1 days.
While his second solo outing, Thor: The Dark
World, is not exactly a fan favorite, the
God of Thunder's story had new life breathed
into it with Thor: Ragnarok.
In this wild adventure, the hero finds himself
stranded and enslaved on the garbage planet
of Sakaar.
This ultimately leads to his being forced
to don armor and enter a gladiatorial arena
to face the Grandmaster's Champion, who turns
out to be none other than Hulk.
The entire scene in the arena is perfectly
executed, from Thor's …
“Hey, hey!
We know each other.
He's a friend from work!"
... line to the movie's nod to everybody's
favorite scene from Avengers …
"Yes!
That's how it feels!"
… to Thor and Hulk's raucous brawl that
ends with the so-called "Lord of Thunder"
electrifying the Jade Giant before being incapacitated
by his obedience disc.
The scene also serves as a sweet shout out
to Hulk's own Planet Hulk story from the comics,
all while kicking off his own three-part story
arc of self-discovery within the MCU.
The first Avengers movie follows Earth's Mightiest
Heroes as they get together for the first
time, iron out their differences, and stop
a Chitauri invasion of New York City led by
Thor's trickster brother Loki.
With so many great scenes unfolding throughout
the film, though, there's one that has to
be called out every time: the shot of the
six heroes, suited up together in the ruined
streets of the Big Apple.
With a portal open above the city and the
fate of the world at stake, the team finally
gets their act together just in time for one
of Steve Rogers' first great moments as a
leader of the Avengers.
With Tony Stark's blessing, Cap takes charge,
assigning roles to each hero and helping contain
the unfolding disaster long enough for the
Iron Avenger to fly an inbound missile through
the wormhole to wrap things up.
"And Hulk."
"Smash."
But it all starts with that one shot, circling
around the six heroes as they stand, back
to back, ready to fight and die doing their
duty.
Marvel had been building to that exact moment
for four straight years, and it serves as
a perfect crescendo.
The MCU has a lot of last-minute arrivals
and nick-of-time heroic entrances that make
you want to get up out of your chair and start
cheering at the top of your lungs.
But there's one scene, in particular, that
has to make it onto the shortlist of greats:
Thor's arrival in Wakanda in Avengers: Infinity
War.
After spending the bulk of the movie off on
his own side quest in search of a new weapon,
the God of Thunder's arrival on the battle-swept
plains of Wakanda is literally electrifying.
It breathes new life into his allies and utterly
terrifies his enemies — those that don't
get blown to smithereens within the first
few seconds, at least.
His added war cry of …
"Bring me Thanos!"
… sends shivers down the spine as he charges
into the fray with Stormbreaker in hand.
The entire event is an optimistic beat in
a movie that generally grows ever bleaker
from the beginning onward, and the thrilling
change of pace is inserted into the narrative
at the perfect moment.
Sometimes the best scenes come in the form
of unexpected sidebars between characters.
In Thor: Ragnarok, the tensions are high when
Thor is thrown into the Grandmaster's prison
after arriving on Sakaar.
He knows that he must face a champion and
still, somehow, find a way to stop his sister
Hela.
And yet, with so much at stake, the narrative
pauses to introduce two new lovable characters:
Korg and Miek, fellow gladiators who quickly
bond with the Asgardian.
"I'm made of rocks as you can see, but don't
let that intimidate you.
You don't have to be afraid unless you're
made of scissors.
Hoo-hoo.
Little rock, paper, scissors joke for ya."
Upon their first meeting after Thor arrives
in the "freaky circle," Korg informs the God
of Thunder about his newfound captivity, fills
him in on numerous details about himself and
his friend Miek, and even goes off on a tangent
about a failed revolution that he tried to
start up.
"Ah, well, I tried to start a revolution but
didn't print enough pamphlets, so hardly anyone
turned up except for my mum and her boyfriend
— who I hate."
The impressive thing about the scene is how
seamlessly it's woven into the greater story,
casually introducing two lighthearted characters
who end up having a massive impact on Thor's
destiny.
Winter Soldier gradually turns up the tension
as Captain America begins to realize the full
extent to which S.H.I.E.L.D. has been infiltrated
by Hydra.
It all comes to a head during a long elevator
ride.
The slow tension of the scene ramps up beautifully
as Cap stands, hands crossed, while more and
more bruisers step onto the lift, filling
it up to maximum capacity.
His line …
"Before we start, does anyone want to get
out?"
… is the perfect kick-off to a fight of
claustrophobically epic proportions.
Within moments, Rogers takes on the entire
elevator, carpeting the floor with his opponents'
knocked out bodies.
The final line — quote, "It kind of feels
personal" — followed by the kick-and-catch
of his shield is pure gravy for a scene that
leaves no doubt that Steve Rogers is a guy
you don't want to mess with.
He may be soft and warm on the outside, but
backed into a corner — or an elevator — the
guy simply can't be brought down.
"I can do this all day..."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.